the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight video well here we are once again
my friends at Sunday night and another
episode of Game of Thrones has just
ended like I do on every Sunday night I
want to give my thoughts on what I think
could happen in the upcoming episode in
this video I want to discuss what I
think will be the inevitable battle for
King's Landing and also the possibility
of another battle on the Blackwater Bay
this next episode is also directed by
Miguel supports Nick and this man is
responsible for directing some of the
biggest battles in Game of Thrones
history so you can almost guarantee we
will see a fight for the Iron Throne in
the very next episode it's no secret
Daenerys Targaryen has come to Westeros
to claim what she believes is rightfully
hers but as we all know Cersei Lannister
is not about to just hand over the Iron
Throne
in fact Cersei is one of the very few
characters who have never really left
King's Landing she has been here ever
since the first season of the show which
is kind of incredible when you think
about it we have seen so many of these
characters travel all over the Seven
Kingdoms everywhere from beyond the wall
and all the way to Essos but Cersei has
remained in King's Landing until the
very end well
we just might see this change by the end
of the next episode like I have said
before I believe Daenerys will be left
with no choice but to attack King's
Landing I think it's only a matter of
time before we see Cersei Lannister
downfall or at least I hope so I have
always thought we would eventually see
the end of Cersei Lannister but Game of
Thrones may try to shock us once again
as you all know Daenerys was ready to
attack King's Landing last season Dany
was ready to take her dragons right into
the city but after talking to her
advisers as well as Jon Snow she decided
not to do that just yet instead Dany
gathered up everything she had to go
help Jon defeat the army of the dead
they were able to get that done in the
last episode but unfortunately they
suffered some heavy casualties
Daenerys had already lost one of her
dragons to the night King now she has
essentially lost
most of her original force although
Danny still has her other two dragons
they still need some new alliances
otherwise they might not be able to take
over King's Landing unless Danny does
have her dragons burn things to the
ground which is what they wanted to
avoid this is exactly what Cersei was
hoping what happened Cersei was hoping
the night king would kill them but if
not then at least she was hoping John
and Danny would lose a lot of their men
that would certainly make the Battle for
King's Landing a hell of a lot more
interesting if they were closer to even
numbers as we all know Cersei did not
have very many Lannister soldiers left
not after what Danny did to them during
the field of fire so it's hard to say
exactly how many Lannister soldiers are
still out there as of right now thanks
to your on Greyjoy Cersei does now have
access to the iron fleet that allowed
Cersei to go and acquire 20,000 new
soldiers from the golden company so now
that John and Danny lost so many men
fighting the night king there is a very
good chance that Cersei has more
soldiers than they do right now that is
until when an F John and Danny get some
new alliances on their side now of
course it doesn't always matter how many
men you have when your enemy has dragons
we have seen just how many soldiers
Danny's dragons can take out within the
matter of seconds but as we all know
Cersei may also have a weapon that can
take out hundreds or thousands of
soldiers at once like I've said before I
am thinking there are still wild fire
underneath King's Landing the Mad King
was hiding wildfire all over the city in
Cersei made sure Qyburn was locating all
the wildfire several seasons ago not
only that but he most likely has learned
how to make his own by now that means
Cersei may be able to set some traps for
Jon and Danny's men
Cersei could have different sections of
the city explode whenever Jon and
Danny's men are nearby the battle for
King's Landing very well could turn into
a massive fireworks display now what's
interesting is not only could we see an
attack on King's Landing but we might
also see something very reminiscent of
the Battle of Blackwater Bay now I'm
obviously making this video before I
have seen the new episode so there is
always a chance that something could
change but as of right now you're on
Greyjoy's entire fleet is sitting out on
the Blackwater Bay this will most likely
be Kings landings first line of defense
against an attack from the water since
Daenerys is coming from Dragonstone she
will fly her dragons right over the bay
and I think you can all guess what would
happen next we have already seen just
how devastating Danny's dragons can be
when they're attacking stationary
objects right before Daenerys Targaryen
left marine she caught the entire Bay on
fire and I think we might see her do the
same thing only this time it will be in
the Blackwater Bay this may have already
been foreshadowed during last season
when Cersei had a conversation with the
man from the iron bank Maya mod owned
the Narrow Sea
Yulin Greyjoy saw mother whose there's
some great Joe is loyal to me for now
tanana's Targaryen has three full-grown
dragons how well do wooden ships fare
against fire-breathing dragons her
dragons might not be as in venerable as
something
as you can see Daenerys may be able to
take out your own Greyjoy's entire fleet
within the hour
however that might be easier said than
done Daenerys should be very careful
because her dragons might be able to be
taken out of the sky some of you might
not remember this but you're on Greyjoy
does have some sort of catapults on his
ships we saw these when the unsullied
captured Casterly Rock if you look very
closely you can see what looks like
fireballs flying through the sky so even
if Daenerys does try to burn all of your
own ships he might be able to have his
men fire right back at her not only that
but Dany also has to be aware of Cersei
and Kai burns ballistas we have already
seen drogon get taken out of the sky
from one of those ballistas
not to mention Danny's dragons are still
trying to recover from their fight
against the army of the Dead both of her
dragons were injured in that battle it's
hard to say how much longer they can
last in all of the battles also like I
said before if Cersei and Qyburn were
smart they would have the ballista set
up all over the city and around the red
key I would have them aiming in every
single direction at the sky so no matter
which way Danny takes her dragons I
would want a ballista within firing
distance Daenerys might kill Cersei and
take back King's Landing for House
Targaryen but it will absolutely come in
a cost she could lose both of her
dragons in the process now it will be
interesting to see how this battle does
actually end something I always like to
reference are the visions Danny and bran
had several seasons ago I think they
would be a lot easier
dismiss if only one of the characters
saw this but since Danny and bran had
the same vision it always made me think
we would see it happen at the very end
of the show when bran stark goes into
the weirwood net for the very first time
he has shown the iron throne covered in
snow some fans said that has to mean
King's Landing gets covered in snow and
maybe that even means the night King
makes it all the way down to King's
Landing however I don't think we have to
see that much snow in King's Landing for
it to be true I think the snow itself is
only meant to be symbolic as in Jon Snow
is the true heir to the Iron Throne now
when Daenerys Targaryen sees this she
also happens to be standing inside of
the Great Hall when she begins to walk
inside she can see all of the
destruction done to the Great Hall
Daenerys is most likely the one that is
responsible for what we see in her
vision nearly all of the damage is up
above which means it was most likely
done by Danny's dragons as you can see
the Iron Throne is covered in snow once
again and like I said that doesn't mean
we will actually have to see snow all
over King's Landing now what I want to
talk about is what Danny does next as we
all know Danny is never able to grab the
Iron Throne she walks out before she
ever does what the hell does that
actually mean based on the way the Great
Hall looks you would think Danny has won
that battle it does look like her
dragons went crazy on the city but if
that's the case why don't we see Danny
claim the Iron Throne do you think
Daenerys might actually die in that
battle or does she not want the Iron
Throne after everything it cost her to
get it well if you go back to the second
episode of this season we hear Jenny
song at the end of the episode right as
Danny finds out she is not the next one
in line for the Iron Throne that song
most likely foreshadows how John and
Danny stories will end one of them may
give up their claim for love but there
is also a second layer to that song that
song was originally about two characters
whose stories ended in a tragedy
basically there was a Targaryen named
Duncan Targaryen he was set to get
married to another woman but he was in
love with Jenny from old stones he
wanted to get married to Jenny but if he
did that then he would lose his claim to
the Iron Throne well he does eventually
give up his claim to marry Jenny but
both of them allegedly died during the
tragedy at Summer Hall so when we hear
that
song during the second episode we
automatically assumed that it relates to
John and Annie's current situation
because the song does end when Danny
goes down into the crypts of Winterfell
that was when John tells her about who
he really is there are so many different
ways you can look at this maybe the song
means John will give up his claim to the
Iron Throne or maybe it means Danny will
give up her claim to the Iron Throne
since we never see Danny grab the Iron
Throne in her house of the undying
vision then you could assume that maybe
she's the one that gives up the claim
however like I said that song is also
about how Duncan and Jenny's story ends
in a tragedy it is said that both of
them died during the fire at summer hall
could that mean John Danny or both of
them died in a fire as well now I know
that some of you think Daenerys cannot
die by fire but that's not the case the
only reason why we have seen her survive
fire before is because blood magic was
involved so could this be the final
shocking event of the series it looks
like the great hall where the iron
throne is located will be on fire next
season hopefully one of them doesn't die
in that very room let me know what you
think happens for the Battle of King's
Landing do you believe we could see the
fight for the Iron Throne end in a
tragedy leave your thoughts down below I
want to thank you all for watching
another video and I also want to thank
everyone for supporting the channel I
hope you all have a great day
I will see you again very soon bye
[Music]